he's like you know what let's play this
whole thing out dude let's play this
whole thing out so i can make him feel
like he has a chance
just so i can take it all away from him
at the very end
this is cyberbullying
and here we go so we have a game we have
the london system
yes and knight c6 another guy who's
going for this knight c6 they got to
start moving that c bun
that's what they got yeah so i i think
again myth is playing
playing sort of the opening setup that i
recommended to um uh
xqc yesterday i think it's pretty
reasonable um
but we're but already myth is thinking
so he's kind of channeling his inner xqc
and thinking here very early in the game
um but he has to have been ready for the
london system because pokeman has played
this i believe every single game so far
how he plays queen b5 good move yeah
very good move by myth
beautifully hits b2 and that stops white
from castling now
pokey seems like a cis like a system
player she really likes to get
kind of a nice comfortable position that
she that she can
mess around in and make things happen
but she's already dealing with some very
serious threats
and we got queen b2 by the way so pokey
plays knight v5
man this is going to get removed from
pokemon really really good
this could get really bad really quickly
because myth
doesn't have a check they're both
covered
he gonna play knight c3 oh my god
i mean i don't know what he's gonna do
here but yeah
we'll see very very soon we'll see he
might play rook c8 i mean he might just
see knight c7 and just play rook to c8
that also could happen
i really want to know on uh he's
clicking around he sees
he saw e6 which by the way might be like
some sort of brilliant sacrifice
crazy attack maybe yeah
oh don't go back to b5 knight cc oh that
would be no
no don't go to b5 don't go back
could go to b7 true true
oh good move by myth good move
once pokemon castles are king myth is in
very bad shape because it's very hard to
develop that being said e6 here would
would actually trap the white knight and
then it's gonna be very hard for pokemon
to respond here
what does she have to play like rugby
one or knight c4 sometimes uh i think
probably c4 and go for queen a4 although
queen b5 unfortunately now allows c4
immediately because the knight protects
c4
if pokeman finds c4 i think she's well
on her way to a victory
he doesn't see this looks very scary
very very scary
um okay yeah she could go
here no my my king takes it actually
never mind i'm trolling
um but the rook don't forget about the
rook my
rook is under threat not good because of
that move she just made
nice
to move the rook over
now if pokemon says queen a4 she's going
to win
as well to trade off some rooks and go
down to the end of the board
yes this is actually an insane position
because white is only up a pawn
but it's plus nine because of how
weak the king is rook b1 like hikaru
said or look for the check
don't go queen c6 do not trade queens
do not try and even then maybe you're
still going to win but don't trade
queens so queen
yeah i think rook b1 and queen a4 both
moves are very cleanly winning here
um i think rook v1 is actually a very
natural move to play here
i think it's a very natural move to to
try and create checkmates also i know
pokemon likes
likes the background checkmate theme so
i can see rook b1 and she can see like
oh no no oh that's a huge mistake
i mean i think she's still going to win
the game but that is a huge mistake by
pokeman
but myth is clicking his king like he's
clicking his king
he he he doesn't even see backward
backward queen right now oh wait no
no he just saw it he just clicked this
queen these guys are terrifying me with
their clicking
you just look at his screen right now
it's it's a
no but he sees that the bishop guards
the queen is he going to trade
oh he played oh oh oh oh no oh
oh no no no no
oh no oh
he saw that he was guarded but he didn't
and look at pokeman
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
she is taking her time i don't think
she's gonna miss it one thing that
pokeman has been really good at
is checkmating pattern she's done a lot
of puzzles and i do think she's gonna
see it
the only reason she might not see this
she might see the fork with knight takes
pawn and just trade the queen
yes she might play queen to and no no no
no just no
clean i really like her have that
that hurts
oh my god i knew i should have just
taken it dude
now pokemon finds knight takes d4 here
i'm gonna be ridiculous
trust yeah knight d4 is crazy having
said that hikaru if she scans for
captures it's the only capture she has
and then she has to find knight f3 true
true well i mean i think that's why
chess is that's also why chess is such a
great game because
you have that learning curve and it's
such a long process i think in many ways
it teaches you
how to learn and how kind of how to lose
and how to persevere and overcome it
and um sort of find that motivation
within yourself
and i think xqc oh no oh no
no no no no what does she think of three
yeah i know when pokeman sees that you
can just tell the way she put her
fingers together that was also another
tale
telltale sign you can tell that you
could tell something was wrong with that
yeah i i wish i was uh oh
just just that expression you could tell
she sensed that something was wrong
there
and again pokemon with the obvious tell
you can you can see how she's looking
she's like
what is what's going on here what is the
idea and unfortunately because it's such
a weird move i think it's pretty obvious
what the idea is on h7
okay well she blunders it okay it's
still winning
for pokemane yeah wow that's actually
lucky i mean if she had moved the other
rook
over it would have been mate like yeah
damn she's gotta go here unfortunately
the white king is still too open here so
pokeman should find a checkmate um but
that being said
at least smith gets something and i
think come on
you go straight ahead go take it
oh you want another one
i like it yeah would you look at that as
two
i could play this game too
take the rook come on
all right come on don't take the pawn
there's a rook on the other side i like
queen h4 just for the
yes just for the idea of making a check
and hoping that pokemon won't see it
uh to be honest don't touch your rook no
don't touch your rook please don't touch
the rook on a1 please just move your
queen
yeah he's um okay good he finally sees
it
so i actually could see he actually
clicked on the rook on a1 when he was
almost like going to play rook d1 so at
least he takes the rook i don't know if
she if she's
lucky or brilliant but queen d8 is made
if the knight isn't there
so exactly yep oh wait like walking on
on a tightrope and like if she moves the
night now thinking it's hanging if she
does not look at queenie two
just looking if she doesn't look for
checks it's very very dangerous it's
it's it
isn't she mated on queen season like
king of but maybe not
almost almost definitely very very close
here
oh yeah okay dude she this is terrifying
like yeah it's almost like there's no
checkmate because white would need to
get the queen to g5
oh my gosh pokemon it's just cokey still
it's not checkmate still i know king e4
is still not made
but you don't go forward oh my
it's wait what how is it a draw exactly
there's probably some repetition here
with like queen c4
queen c3 c4 you can check on c4 c3 and
f5 you go f7 c4 you do the yoyo oh
yo yo between f7 c4 and c4 c3 it's just
a classic yo-yo
and it's like the yo-yo where you uh
what do you call it i don't know what
you call where did that even come from
yo-yo
around the moon i don't know anyway
whatever um it just
said yo-yo yeah because it's a yo-yo you
see it's like
one end up back i know yeah it's not
like
you're right i used to play the yo-yo
but i don't know what you call that that
anyway whatever okay is that an xqc
thing or you just made that up i just
made that all back
beautiful beautiful
we just witnessed history you are the
first grand master to ever call a
maneuver like that a yo-yo
so it's uh but myth takes mitt doesn't
realize that he's in grave danger
the scissor or the ladder sorry check on
g2 and go queen h1
yeah um it's time for essentially g1
also yeah
you see is it
oh wait all the ambulance
okay why'd you you got us all the way
over here for this
well she she really got my hopes up you
know that
i that's so disrespectful dude that is
so rude
she really did she really she's like you
know what let's play this whole thing
out dude
let's play this whole thing out so i can
make him feel like he has a chance just
so i can take it all away from him at
the very end
this is cyberbullying
i can't believe it
i know i know
it's me
oh i was sweating at the end there
i won't lie uh pokey how uh how did that
match go
expectations versus reality how was that
um
to be honest i have not been practicing
enough chess and my chest vision was
quite off today that's why i had to
keep putting on the goggles um yes
that was trash talk we thought you were
like we thought you were like zero
oh no no no that's me like looking for
the right move you know
that's what i was missing yeah
i'll watch my goggles next time don't
worry thanks
but yeah i think it went i mean i'm glad
i won
but myth has been practicing pretty well
he could have taken it for sure
but you know i got like 200 rating on
him so i need to win right
that's the expectation i mean yeah we've
had uh
we've had all sorts of crazy matches so
rating hasn't always
but yes i mean i guess going in uh you
would be the favorite myth
um we speaking of you know favorites we
were saying you were in the group of
death in the group in the early stage
right like did you feel that way
how did that how's your chest been since
you
kind of kicked this whole process off in
january uh up to now
the group of the group of death yeah we
thought that it was kind of insane with
sardosh and benji
and um overall like
i've just been having a great time
playing chess i don't think i've
put in as much time as i would uh have
liked to
overall there's a lot of things to work
on and
to uh for me to do but overall like i
think this has been
a really great introduction to chess and
i'm excited to like
keep at it you know and i think that's
the important thing that i'm getting out
of this
is like you know i've become interested
in this game
because of this event and because of you
know
just the excitement around versing some
of you know some people like pokey and
and nico and benji and just the hype all
around it so i definitely
want to you know move forward with it
which i think
yeah that's that's important for me
newbie group next time
and it's me and myth in it yup
straight to the top yeah but uh no yeah
for sure this is it's been extremely
like motivating and even like
playing against these like i guess like
the juggernaut players in the group
and still being able to like you know
make some things happen or it being like
me just not seeing one move
to it being like a really really close
match or like me getting even ahead just
off of missing one move
is really like obviously it could be
really the motivating but it's something
to learn from
and it's uh it's motivating also in the
same exact way
so i want to keep it up well um
thank you to you both of you for the
match uh
myth hope to see you playing chess on
stream in the future and pokey will see
you for the semis
thank you for having us
you